[Music]
there just seems to be no end to the
actresses coming forward with
allegations against Harvey Weinstein of
sexual abuse and harassment
now it's Oscar winner Lupita Nyong'o
sharing her disturbing story she claims
Weinstein tried to force her into a
sexual situation not once but twice
Lupita tells the New York Times she
first met the producer in 2011 three
years before winning an Oscar for 12
years a slave now long after she says
Weinstein invited her to his home to
watch a film once there she claims
Weinstein led her into a bedroom and
offered to give her a massage she
declined quote I thought he was joking
at first he was not for the first time
since I met him I felt unsafe Lupita
says that to get out of the situation
she offered to give him a massage
instead when Weinstein informed her that
he wanted to remove his pants
she left another time at dinner she says
Weinstein told her let's cut to the
chase I have a private room upstairs
where we can have the rest of her meal
she also declined that offer the
producer who is currently in treatment
for sex addiction said through a
spokesperson mr. Weinstein has a
different recollection of the events but
believes Lupita is a brilliant actress
and a major force for the industry and
there's more fallout today the actress
Shaun young known for the movie Blade
Runner claims Weinstein sexually
harassed her too she told an Austin
podcast she rejected his advances while
working on a movie in 1992 the minute
you actually stand up for yourself in
Hollywood you're the crazy one forty six
women have come forward claiming
Weinstein sexually abused or harassed
them including one who has prompted an
LAPD investigation the alleged victim a
38 year old Italian actress is not being
identified by name but her attorney
spoke to reporters this victim described
to the LAPD extremely serious sexual
assault and a rape Weinstein
spokesperson says quote mr. Weinstein
obviously can't speak to anonymous
allegations but he unequivocally denies
allegations of non-consensual sex
[Music]
you